Перемикачі світла - це вчорашній день,
переконана дизайнерка Марія Люміаго.
Світло в її новій квартирі вмикається й вимикається
датчиками руху або зі смартфона.
Home remote control зветься ця система.
Марія - одна з перших мешканок Каласатами –
району майбутнього у Гельсінкі.
Квартири майбутнього - один з найбільших
девелоперських проектів у Фінляндії.
За кілька років сюди мають переїхати
щонайменше 25 тисяч людей.
"Smart Kalasatama" – майбутня "розумна" частина Гельсінкі.
Настільки розумна, що кожен її мешканець
отримає додаткову годину щодня. Завдяки таким
інтелектуальним рішенням, як розумна енергія,
транспортне сполучення, економіка
спільного використання або логістика.
Нові квартири мають бути доступними для багатьох.
Зараз це поки великий будівельний майданчик.
Проте вже помітні ознаки
"інтелектуальної системи". Приміром,
підземна система прийому та транспортування
відходів. Або каршеринг з електромобілями.
Але головне у проекті – це ефективні
енергетичні рішення.
Найважливіший аспект –
близькість до електростанцій
та за рахунок цього краще енергопостачання.
Ще є система, яка поліпшить звичні, щоденні речі.
Наприклад, тимчасовий прокат паркувальних місць.
У райончику вже проживають 300 людей.
Вони від самого початку були залучені
до проектування будинків. Навіть цього будинку
для літніх людей.
На цих інтерактивних екранах – інформація
про тиждень, зокрема меню та прогноз погоди.
А в новій школі замість класів – відкриті навчальні зони.
Архітектори переконані:
цей проект може стати прикладом
для інших європейских міст у майбутньому.
Завершити його мають до 2035 року.